♪ ♪
>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT
"NOTABLE QUOTABLES" CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER STYLE.
>> LET ME GIVE A PIECE OF
ADVICE.
WHEN THERE IS A SUIT BETWEEN
THE STATE OF OBAMA AGAINST THE
LITTLE SISTERS OF THE POOR,
TAKE THE SIDE OF THE LITTLE OF
THE POOR.
I HAVE A SOFT SPOT.
IT COULD BE BECAUSE I WAS IN
MY YOUTH A LIBERAL.
I RETAIN THE MARSHMALLOW DEEP
INSIDE MY HEART.
THE PITY IS THIS.
THIS IS THE STRONGEST FIELD OF
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES AND
INSTEAD ALL OUR TIME IS SPENT
DISCUSSING THIS RODEO CLOWN.
I'M THE BEST PRESIDENT I HAVE
EVER BEEN?
THAT IS A PRETTY LOW BAR.
THIS IS WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
WHEN YOU LIVE IN A BANANA
REPUBLIC.
EVERY TIME LIBERALS LOSE THEY
ACCUSE THE OTHER SIDE OF ALL
KIND OF ISMS.
THE WORLD IS GOING TO HELL IN
A HAND BASKET.
IT WILL SNOW IN HELL BEFORE
THE D.O.J. IS GOING TO GO
AFTER HER.
HIDE SEAN SPICER, WITNESS
PROTECTION PROGRAM SOMEWHERE
IN IOWA I THINK WOULD HELP.
AND TAKE AWAY THE PRESIDENT'S
TWEETING MACHINE.
LOSER BY FAR, MELISSA
McCARTHY.
SHE LOST OLD SPICEY.
SHE WILL MISS HIM.
SHE DIDN'T JUST LOSE A GUY.
SHE KILLED HIM.
>> Bret: YOU OFFICIALLY ARE
PUTTING A BLACK CHIP NOW ON
DONALD TRUMP ON CANDIDATE
CASINO.
>> I PUT $100 ON MONDAY.
I LEFT $10 SO I CAN GET REALLY
DRUNK.
>> Bret: YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH WINE, WOMEN AND SONG,
OPIOIDS.
>> I STARTED A TREND.
THE OTHER ONLY OPTION IS AN
ACT OF GOD.
AND HE APPEARS TO BE OTHERWISE
OCCUPIED RIGHT NOW.
>> Martha: SURE YOU TUNE IN
TONIGHT.
>> Bret: OR SET THE D.V.R.
FOR 9:00 SPECIAL EVENT.
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER IN HIS OWN